[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره اهلا بكم قوات الاحتلال تقتل
فلسطينيين خلال اقتحامها مدينه جنين
مداهمات واعتقالات في الضفه الغربيه تطالو
خمسين شخصا ونتنياهو يقول ان الهجمات ضد
الاسرائيليين في ذروتها ويتهم ايران ومن
وصفهم باتباعها بالوقوف وراها
مجلس السلم والامن في الاتحاد الافريقي
يعلق عضويه النيجر بسبب الانقلاب ويؤكد
انه يدرس قرار اكواس نشر قوه هناك ويطلب
دراسه تدعيه المحتمله في الاثناء افادت
الاذاعه الرسميه الجزائريه بان الجزائر
رفضت طلب فرنسا سماح لطائرتها العسكريه
باستخدام اجواء البلاد لمهاجمه النيجر
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامبي
يعلن في منشور على منصه تروت سوشيال انه
يعتزم تسليم نفسه الخميس الى سجن مقاطعه
فولتون بولايه جورجيا تنفيذا لطلب المدعي
العامه على خلفيه اتهامه تتعلق بالغاء
نتائج انتخابات عام 2020 في الولايه
شركه ميتا تستعد لاطلاق ميزات جديده في
تطبيق فريدز من بينها اتاحه نسخه اصدار
الويب بعد مغادره اكثر من نصف مستخدم
التطبيق منذ اطلاقه ومن المتوقع ان تساهم
الميزه في زياده انتشار التطبيق لاسيما
انه سيسهل اداره حسابات العلامه التجاريه
والشركات والصحفي الى اللقاء